Tom Brady the goat I mean first of all
this is how he grips it one and four
ring finger on one pinky on four and he
really gets his hand on there to kind of
get the knuckle of his fingers on the
laces kind of the small part of the ball
he's a guy that's got big hands to begin
with so the ball must almost feel like a
baseball in his hand the way he throws
it and quite honestly the way he swings
it around it looks like a baseball
sometimes it's that special people who
say you can't change a guy's throwing
motion yes you can you can change a guy
that's gifted at throwing he can tinker
with it and change his throwing motion
tom brady would be evident number one
for a while tom brady 2009 2010 11 12
okay the motion was very vertical it
came from here and it went down and I
did not think honestly some of those
years were Tom Brady's best years
yeah the completion percentage was good
and things like that but big-time throws
game-changing type throws I thought were
limited in those years in 2014 and I've
noticed this in his warmups anybody
watch him warm up he warms up and he
does this a lot right to emphasize
coming across his body to throw the ball
again if you want to throw the ball hard
that way and far that way your power has
to be applied going that way you can't
have a motion that goes from here to
here and think you're gonna throw the
ball far that way that'll never work so
that's a great example of a guy who is
gifted and he's tinkered and changed his
motion to become better and even more
efficient later on in his career watch
him right now any young quarterback
anybody there's so many things he does
the right way first of all dropping back
he's very graceful and get out from
underneath the center keeps the ball
about right here right to where he's
relaxed in his upper body it's not up
here and tight it's not too low to where
it's so relaxed and it looks stupid it's
a very efficient motion the one-in-four
grip two hands on the ball he's got
everything lined up properly and when it
comes time to throw he really does a
great job of turning that shoulder he
keeps this an hand in there pretty tight
because a lot of times the throwing arm
might mimic
the other arm that's off the ball so he
keeps it in there pretty tight and then
when it comes time to throw it's pretty
efficient it's a little
and it's perfect and that's why he's Tom
Brady and he's usually on the money
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports